[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello how's it going hey Jeremy what's
new and not much our subscribers they
want us to do another collaboration I
mean we did the three pointed ninja star
before but have you seen my latest model
the five-pointed ninja star no I didn't
know that was possible
cool you think you can mail it to me so
I can learn it mail it haven't you seen
the new matter transmitter portal screen
technology uh you mean like beaming no I
didn't know you could do that already
yeah hold on though let me grab my
granny glasses just in case all right
I'm ready hey wow that's a cool star I
wonder if it'll work with my ninja star
gun are you ready no we oh yeah I'm okay
I got another I it's fine but man that
thing shoots hard darn I almost had them
on you got me back man that thing is
powerful so can you show me how to do it
forget showing you haven't you heard of
the newest info telekinetic pulse
technology ah here we go again
look just put your head on the computer
screen and you'll know it in seconds all
right Wow
so you just take a couple of piece of
paper whoa that's awesome and it's
really easy too
we should definitely teach our
subscribers how to make it yeah you bet
let's go hey what's going on guys and
welcome to my tutorial for the
five-pointed ninja star or Pentastar
this is a long-awaited collaboration you
guys requested between myself and Jeremy
Shafer as you saw I finally got him back
for poking me in the eye
in my last video that you could find
here the three pointed ninja star I'm
also really happy about the feedback
that I got so I'm glad you guys liked it
here are some of the top comments that
you guys left
on the last video to make the
five-pointed ninja star you're going to
need five pieces of paper I'm going to
be using colored printer paper that I'm
going to turn square and I'll show you
how to do that
you can even use smaller sheets like
this to make a mini one or you can use a
word ami paper whatever you prefer if
you do enjoy the video be sure to give
it a thumbs up or a like down below and
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell so you get all
notifications from my channel once you
have the printer paper the square paper
or the origami paper you're ready to go
the first thing we need to do is turn
each of the papers into the waterbomb
base so just take the other papers and
lay them aside take the top right corner
and the top edge and fold it down to the
left side make a nice sharp crease along
that edge and flip it over now you can
take the top edge and fold it down until
it meets that folded edge then make a
nice sharp crease along that edge and
then you could tear it off now that we
have a fold going this way we're going
to take the other corner and fold it to
the opposite corner take the other
corner and fold it across to the
opposite corner and make a crease open
it you'll see you have an X take the top
edge and fold it down to the bottom edge
open it up and then turn it 90 degrees
once again fold the top edge now to the
bottom edge when you open it up you'll
see you have an X and a plus and you're
ready for the waterbomb base take the
top edge and fold it down to the bottom
edge now to make the waterbomb we
basically open these two flaps the paper
and we tuck this edge into the middle
like this and we close it so that we
have two flaps on the right do the same
with the other side open the two edges
of the paper and push down on that edge
until you have the two flaps you might
have to fix some of those wrinkles but
squeeze the two flaps together and
you're finished and there you go that's
how to make the waterbomb base now we
need to do that with the other four
sheets as you saw I went through in
detail you're going to make an X in the
paper and a plus and then you're going
to tuck both of those edges in so just
do that with all five of the sheets fold
it corner to corner edge to edge and
then tuck the edges in that way you have
four flaps on
each waterbomb base and there you go now
you should have five water bomb bases
from the water bomb base is we're going
to create five modules I'll go through
with you how to create one in detail and
then you can make the rest of the four
to make the first module we're going to
take this first top flap and we're going
to take this outside edge and fold it
down onto the middle line just like this
so take the edge fold it down right on
to the middle line and then make a
gentle crease you don't have to go too
hard just like that
do the same with all three of the
remaining flaps fold the outside corner
on to the middle line
flip it over and do the exact same thing
remember you don't have to be too hard
on the edge because we are going to be
joining them together now that we have
something like this we're going to take
these two side flaps and we're going to
open them just like this and then you
can push and make sure that it's nice
and flat now one of the important things
that you have to recognize is that these
flaps are folded to the outside so it
should look like an M you do not want
these flaps folded on the inside like
this you want the flaps folded on the
outside so that the modules look just
like this and that's how to create one
of the modules so now you have to do
that with the remaining four water bomb
bases with the last four water bombs
take the two top flaps fold them down to
the center line take the two bottom
flaps and then open the two side flaps
and flatten it out making sure that the
two top flaps form an M that is
important when you're done you'll have
five completed modules you could join
together again just on the last one
remember we're taking the two side flaps
and opening them up you're not going to
take these bottom flaps and open them up
because this is not the module you want
as you'll see in this module these flaps
are folded to the inside
that's not what we want and this is very
important so be sure that you're taking
the side flaps opening them up so that
when you look at it from the front like
this you see an M and they're folded to
the outside these flaps are folded to
the outside like this and now you should
have five modules that look just like
this to join two of the modules we're
going to face the flaps towards one
another and the flaps on the right are
going to go into the pockets here on the
flaps on the left so you're going to
take the two you're going to insert both
of the flaps like this and you're just
going to push now if you have any
difficulty just kind of work it around
like this until both of the modules are
touching like this so you see the
outside red flap or the left side module
flap on the outside of the right side
flap same thing with the back then lay
it down and you're going to open the
middle you're going to flatten
everything out and you're going to fold
this entire module on the right along
this vertical line just like this then
just flatten everything out and you're
ready to join another module now what
you need to do with these top flaps of
the module you just joined is just take
them and remember we're going to create
an M so just make mountain folds out of
the flaps like this and bring them
together then you can kind of just
squeeze them like this and lay it down
grab another module and once again point
these flaps towards those flaps remember
the flaps on the right are going into
the pockets on the flaps on the left
open them up if it helps you a little
bit better take the flaps on the right
put them into the flaps on the left
once you see these two edges lined up
just push and you're going to open this
middle portion here like that and you're
going to flatten everything out making
good creases here and good creases all
around then once again take this entire
module and fold it along this vertical
line and fold it over just like that
then you can just kind of push down on
it and you'll have something like this
again to join the next module we're
taking the top module and we're just
gonna pinch those edges like that the
corners so that they form an M and the
right flaps are going to go into the
left flap so if you want to put your
finger in and open it up a little bit on
the left side that'll work
push them together flatten the middle
out and then you could fold the whole
right module all the oil just like that
again pinch those flaps forms an EM
squeeze them together and the last
module which is the yellow module the
right side flaps which is the yellow
flaps are going to go into the flaps
flatten it out and then fold it over
just like that and now you should have
something that looks just like this
now that you have something like this
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the flaps of the last two modules
or the end modules and we're going to
fold them in like we would if we're
going to add another module so just kind
of pinch them like this and spread them
out turn it over this one is going
inside like this and like that now
remember the last module is going to be
receiving the flaps of the first module
the red is my first module the yellow is
my last module take the flaps of the end
modules and just pinch them like that
and the yellow is going to be receiving
the flaps of the red so these flaps are
going
into the flaps on the yellow module my
knees you just open the yellow module
flaps a little and you're going to tilt
it up like this and you might need to
just bend these a little bit and insert
it like that do the same thing with the
other one now remember this flat needs
to go into this pocket so take it push
it into the pocket just like that
remember the last module is receiving
the flaps of the first one and then just
kind of work them together and just give
it a nice pinch now you can lay the
whole thing flat and flatten everything
out so now you should have something
that looks like this now this next part
gets a little bit tricky but what I want
you to notice is that if you open up
like this
there are flaps that are on the outside
these outside flaps should be facing the
right so I'm just gonna take the whole
thing and just spin it around like this
so now if you just lift up anything
you'll see that these flaps that are on
the outside are pointed to the right and
that's the way that you want it it
doesn't matter really where you split
this up but you're going to take it and
you're going to lay the whole model flap
so think of it like a book you can just
squeeze three on the left two on the
right doesn't matter
so the first module is on the right here
and the last modules on the left what
you're going to do is you're going to
take the right module and you're going
to take this edge and you're going to
fold it onto the horizontal line here so
I'm going to take it and fold it up onto
the horizontal line push it along this
vertical line so just put your finger
here you're going to take your right
finger and you're going to kind of run
along that crease until you have about a
thumbs width of folded edge here once
you have a thumbs width of folded edge
here what you're going to do or what I'd
like to do is to make a mark on this
edge that's about an inch long so just
make a mark on the
and eggs that you just fold it up that's
about an inch long then you can unfold
it and what you're going to do is you're
just going to take the whole red module
and like a page of a book you're just
going to turn it then again lift it up
make sure that this flap that's on the
outside is facing to the right it should
be on the right side now if there come
apart that's fine that's not a big deal
take the edge of the orange module now
and fold it up to the edge start in the
middle here and crease it until you're
about an inch from the edge of this
little outside flat so about a thumbs
width again just kind of crease it like
that about an inch long and now we're
going to make a mark on this folded edge
of the orange module and that mark again
should be about an inch long unfold it
and turn the page well you have no more
pages so we're going to go to the left
we already did the red one so turn the
page again lift it up make sure that
this outside flap is facing to the right
and we're going to do the yellow one now
take the bottom edge of the yellow
module and fold it onto the horizontal
line and then you're going to make the
crease from the outside of the flap
about an inch away and then you're going
to make a mark on the yellow edge then
take the purple take the edge and fold
it up to the horizontal line if they
have Frankel's it's okay to make that
crease about an inch and then you can
make that mark on the purple and flip it
over so when you flip it you're just
going to flip it like this flip it like
this now we didn't do the blue module
yet when you lift it up yes this flap is
facing to the right so we're going to do
the blue module again don't worry if
there's a little separation between the
modules it's not a big deal
you could try to kind of squeeze it
together lift it up edge on the
horizontal line push down and crease it
about an inch from here and make a mark
you should see that we have one two
three four five marks we're almost done
now you want to take a look at these
corners here where the two modules meet
now if you can see those markings I had
this is the same side that was facing
towards us when we were making those
folds you're going to take the two
corners where those modules meet and
you're going to pinch them all the way
into the center of the ninja star do the
same for all five of the corners where
the modules meet so just take them grab
them and squeeze them and you can kind
of give them a little bit of a push
and also pinch push it down just
slightly and just move your fingers all
the way to the middle until you make a
little bit of a crease do the same thing
with the remaining ones grab them and
just push on it a little bit and then
you can make a little bit of a crease
where those two modules meet and you'll
basically open it up like a flower
almost once you're done you'll have
something that looks a little bit like
this
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take each of these corners and
we're going to meet it up with that line
that I had to make so it doesn't matter
where you start let's start with this
one we're going to take this and we're
going to just take it and we're going to
slide it up until it meets that line
wherever it meets the line is where you
want to just push it and you're going to
flip it over once you flip it now you
can make a crease on this module which
happens to be purple
okay so you're going to make a crease on
the module that has the mark take it
hold it there
flip it over and as you'll see this is
the crease we're going to make you're
just going to take your finger and
you're going to pinch it right there and
it doesn't matter which way we move
we'll take this one and again take it
slide it up wherever it meets that you
hold it you could hold it with your left
thumb
flip it over and you're going to make a
crease on the yellow module now and then
just do the same for the rest take the
corner and then slide it up to the line
hold it there flip it over and then
you're going to crease all the way in
take the next corner slide it up to the
line and you're gonna crease on the
orange all the way until your fingers
can't go any more then take the other
corner slide it up the line and then
you're going to crease on the blue edge
now what we can do is we can actually
take these corners and on the module
that we made the line we're going to
tuck it underneath this little pocket
here so just tuck it underneath there
and again just reinforce that little
crease you made and you can go in a
clockwise direction so just tuck this
one now underneath that one take the
next one fold it down we already made
the crease here on the yellow module so
just tuck it inside the yellow module by
opening this flap and pushing down take
the last one we're going to put it
inside of the red module go like that
and it looks like we do have one more
remember we did make this crease on the
orange module just take it and tuck it
inside the orange module so now you
should have something that looks like
this all right so if you made it this
far you've gotten past the hard part
there's just one thing if you do see
that these aren't completely tucked
under what you can do is just tuck them
under like that with your finger and
it'll make it look a little bit nicer
but it's not a big deal it'll still come
out and just give it a push this one
seems to not want to go under then you
could flip the model over and you'll
have something like this now this is the
pretty easy part what you're going to do
is going to open up to module edges like
this and you're going to kind of walk
your finger into the middle once you get
this this point right here you're going
to pinch it just like this so just walk
your fingers
into the middle and pinch the edge do
the same with all four so just turn it
walk your fingers up and make sure to
also pinch this outside flap do the same
with the remaining corners whelk your
fingers in and pinch the edge until you
have all five of them pinched
once you have all five corners pinched
what you're going to do is you're
actually just going to fold it to the
right just like this so just fold it
wherever it wants to be full it wants to
fold directly to the right just push it
down like that and then just make a
crease right along this edge here do the
same thing for all five so just fold it
to the right do that with all the
corners fold and push fold it to the
right and push down and crease push the
last one down in crease and once you
have that with all five of the edges
just like this then all you need to do
is to do the same thing we did on the
other side you're going to take the
corner that we pinched and you're going
to tuck it into the next modules flap
the left flap here so just open it up
tuck it underneath and you can go in a
clockwise direction if you like it may
help to bend the tips a little bit to
get them into the module but do the same
with the orange one the red one yellow
one goes into the pocket on the left of
the red and then the purple the yellow
then once you're done make sure
everything is nice and flat and you've
completed the five-pointed ninja star to
throw it I found the best way to do it
is to kind of angle it down like this
and flick your wrists sort of like this
also you can put your finger on the tip
of one of the corners and just flick it
like that you can also try to throw it
like this overhand but it doesn't work
as well
and if you want to try it with the ninja
star gun then I made the mini one you
grab it like this and whoa just always
be sure to wear glasses if you're going
to shoot it at your computer with your
portal technology on
gone there is how thank you guys so much
for watching the video I hope you
enjoyed it if you did enjoy it be sure
to give it a big thumbs up or like down
below and let me know what you thought
by leaving a comment in the comments
section thank you guys so much for all
the feedback on the ninja star gun I'm
glad that you liked it I was a little
bit sick when I made it but I'm feeling
a whole lot better now so thanks a lot
for your consideration also a big thanks
to Jeremy for doing the collaboration
with me sorry about your eye man no
worries I'll be fine
alright there'll be a link to his
tutorial somewhere at the end of the
video and also into the description I
was thinking of maybe doing a boomerang
next but let me know what you want to
see down in the comments section below
don't forget to hit the subscribe button
down below and also the Bell so that
you've received all notifications from
my channel and be sure to watch out for
flying ninja stars out of your computer
portal I'll see you guys next time